and let's jump into the first story it
is but a tweet
from glenn greenwald who says ukraine
has biological research facilities says
under secretary of state victoria nuland
when asked by senator rubio if ukraine
has biological or chemical weapons and
says she's worried russia may get them
but set but she says she's 100 sure that
if there's a biological attack it's
russia
and actually
marco rubio
intervened in her in her uh her answer
to answer for her and it is one of the
most disgusting things marco rubio man
talk about a bad person but let me play
for you this clip because this is truly
revealing well um i only have a minute
left let me ask you um
does ukraine have chemical or biological
weapons
ukraine has a
biological research facilities
which in fact we are now quite concerned
russian troops russian forces
may be seeking to
uh gain control of so we are working
with the ukrainians on how they can
prevent any of those
research materials from falling into the
hands of
russian forces should they approach i'm
sure you're aware that the russian
propaganda
groups are already putting out there all
kinds of information about how they've
uncovered a plot by the ukrainians to
release biological weapons in the
country and with nato's coordination if
there's a biological or chemical weapon
incident or uh or attack inside of
ukraine is there any doubt in your mind
that 100 percent it would be the
russians that would be behind it there
is no doubt in my mind senator and it is
classic
russian
uh technique to blame on the other guy
what they're planning to do themselves
wow if there was anything that could
remove all confidence i had in what
victoria newland was saying it's marco
rubio teeing up the answer to her of
course if there isn't it's russia right
you agree it's russia yes okay then yo
just let her answer the questions but
but i digress here we have under
secretary of state saying
well there's uh
there's bio labs in ukraine and we're
concerned russia could get them now
let's just put aside anything outside of
this because there were conspiracies i i
don't know anything outside of that let
me just say
is it is it a serious concern for us in
the united states that ukraine has bio
labs what are they researching i don't
know what if russia gets a hold of them
is there something there that we should
be concerned about is this may be why
vladimir putin says i'm going into
ukraine because that was what a lot of
people were saying now that's not a
conspiracy theory if you are speculating
that the motive of vladimir putin was to
gain access to research facilities i'd
say that's war like if you have a
military base and another country
invades to gain control of that base i'd
be like okay
so is that maybe what we're looking at
uh well i just want to mention something
about secretary of state newland here
she's very interesting figure so one
thing that she mentioned
in 2013 is that the united states
government had spent over five billion
dollars trying to promote democracy in
ukraine and there was a leaked phone
call between her and america's
ambassador
to europe where she was discussing who
who she thought would be a good leader
for ukraine and wouldn't you know it
just happens by coincidence a couple
weeks later that person becomes prime
minister huh
and yeah and so we talk about how russia
is spending 46 and not even russia
non-state actors in russia spending 46
thousand dollars on facebook ads was a
quote-unquote act of war
and the united states government has
thrown literal billions of dollars at
ukraine to influence their leadership
this woman was on the phone on record
saying there was a specific person she
wanted in charge of government there
that person ends up in that position
weeks later
and i'm supposed to trust this person
that they have the best interest of that
nation in mind and that she's going to
tell me about russia's nefarious deeds
the cia just overthrew i mean they were
part of the coup
of ukraine when they put in poroshenko
and yeah i mean that's that's just on
the table now
2014. everything i look at says there's
overwhelming evidence the united states
now that we've accepted that the cia has
been involved with the overthrow and i'm
like is there evidence that says that
what we need that that's not this is
what so it's not
this every time i ask it they're like
yeah it's totally totally confirmed
you on the show like last week no no it
was heavily speculated first of all
there were major protests in ukraine it
is widely speculated believed the west
was well first of all it's a fact the
west was very much supporting the
euromaidan protests that doesn't mean
the u.s
made yanukovych flee there's a big
difference between the cia actually
having agents and assets going in and
doing these things
now that being said i would not be
surprised in any sense uh that the the
that this year
did this i'm just i want to be very very
careful and precise yeah because
what i'm saying then because we're
dealing with the fact that the under
secretary just said there are bio labs
okay let's start from there is russia
pissed about that very well maybe
now we have this story from music today
this is why getting the fact perfect is
important
they say fact check
false claim of u.s bio labs in ukraine
tied to russian disinformation campaign
so right right there you have
interesting points u.s bio labs okay
well they're ukrainian according to vic
uh uh victoria newland she said ukraine
has biolabs so you see how they do this
they slap u.s bio labs in front of bio
labs and all of a sudden the whole story
is fake yeah so yeah exactly they
fact-check a different story than the
one that's actually being discussed and
then any time the story comes up they
get to slap false on it so here's what
they say the claim there are bio labs in
ukraine funded by the us government now
i will i will say we we read on this
show a u.s government site talking about
u.s funded research and bio labs in
ukraine so i don't know what that was
all about they say in the early morning
hours putin launched a full scale
military blah blah blah similar posts
claimed russia destroyed seven of the 11
supposed labs and missile strikes the
claims are wrong independent faction
outlets reported i actually don't think
those claims are true to be honest
because we looked at the map of missile
strikes in the map of labs and they
don't line up it's like weird that
people would make that claim
when all you need to do is say
putin's mad about labs he's probably
blown up stuff near the lab so that he
can take the labs
i i would yeah i would assume russia
wants the bio labs as newland actually
said in front of marco rubio regarding
russia would seize them if it's war or
not i think historically you see border
skirmishes that aren't considered war
like if an enemy is setting up artillery
on on the border on the other side of
the border from your country you may
send in a party to destroy the artillery
and then come back and it's not really
an act of war it's more of just like or
sometimes they'd go in and they'd steal
food from like the enemy but it wasn't
really war you ready for this part of
the same article oh yeah the same
article says the ukrainian and u.s
governments partnered in august 2005 to
prevent the proliferation of dangerous
pathogens and related expertise and to
minimize potential biological threats
according to the treaty interfax ukraine
reported in may 2020 that part of the
agreement was aimed at modernizing state
laboratories in the odessa kharkiv
leviev kiev venice vinistia kersen and
de nippa petrovsk regions i'm trying
those efforts included making repairs
updating equipment and purchasing
supplies
the security service of ukraine to the
laboratory's finance from the state
budget are subordinate to the ministry
of health and the state services on food
safety and consumer protection according
to interfax ukraine the u.s embassy in
ukraine sought to set the record
straight on these bio labs claim in
april 2020 calling the theories
disinformation spreading in some circles
in ukraine that mirrors russian
disinformation regarding the strong u.s
ukrainian partnership to reduce
biological threats it sure sounds like
they're trying really hard to claim that
although the us did partner and help
ukraine with a lot of the work they were
doing in certain biological areas these
are not us bio labs okay well no that's
true they're not they're ukrainian but
is the u.s involved i'd you'd like to
know well usually they hire a company
like eco health alliance to get involved
for them so that they can wipe their
hands of it well yeah what's with our
country and like funding all of this
insane biological research around the
globe as you know we saw with the the
wuhan lab too and i think you know this
goes back to i you know the way this war
has been presented to us in the media is
that you know ukraine is the good guys
who can do no wrong and everything we
have to take
the government of ukraine's word over
over anything else and as we've seen
we've been fed so many so many lies as
this war has happened between you know
imminent nuclear meltdown that turned
out to be false as zolensky was calling
for a no-fly zone i think it just goes
back when you're in a war propaganda is
very important and propaganda to help
your side win is very important and a
lot of that is being
a lot of that is just being fed to us by
our media i want to i want to read the
last portion of this article they say
because this is interesting based on our
research we write false the claim that
there are u.s bio labs in ukraine funded
by the us government the posts
misrepresent a treaty between the united
states and ukraine aimed at preventing
biological threats the labs are owned
and funded by the ukrainian government
the security service of ukraine and the
us embassy in ukraine have said the
claim is false reports indicate the
claim is tied to a years-long russian
disinformation campaign aimed at
discrediting the u.s okay fair i totally
accept all of that okay so ukraine does
have bio labs right so when when the
narrative came out that russia was
concerned about bio labs in ukraine
that was legitimate yep like is russia
really concerned about that all right
sorry sorry everybody you know that
they're spreading this disinformation
how about we just talk about the truth
that there are biological research
facilities in ukraine and that russia
wants to seize them well because or the
us fears russia will yeah well like i
said on our last episode the only time
you need to really come in with these
fact checks is if there's some kernel of
truth that you don't want people
discussing that seems to be the case
very often maybe i'm being a little
hyperbolic but we see it frequently and
i will say this after the last five or
six years it is absolutely laughable
that they think they would have any
credibility talking about a
biological laboratories bioweapons labs
and where they're getting their funding
and b russian disinformation it doesn't
exactly bolster my confidence in the
veracity of their claims that they're
using that phrase thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm we'll see you all there
you